يبدو أن [الموسيقى]
في كل هذه الرؤى الخاصة
بوسائل النقل في المستقبل
تبدو
مضمونة لأنهم حصلوا أخيرًا
على ساعات النوم الموصى بها
بحيث يكون لديهم وقت فراغ أكبر من أي وقت
مضى أو لأنهم لم يعودوا بحاجة إلى
إيقاف
السيارات التي أظهرها هذا العرض التلفزيوني حرفيًا
يصفه بأنه مطهر ،
فهذه هي قصة الأشخاص مقابل
وقوف السيارات
، يجب أن تجعلك تتساءل بينما نقوم بترقية
النقل وتحويل المدن ،
فهل يصبح مجتمعنا مكانًا أفضل
في
المستقبل ، حيث يسهل التنقل بسهولة
مع العديد من الخيارات للأشخاص الذين
سيذهبون إليه  كن صديقًا للبيئة
وصحيًا من منظور تعليمي
صحيًا
من خلال توفير الوظائف والناس لديهم
الوقت
إلى الوراء.
نحن نفعل المزيد من الفصل العنصري أكثر مما
لدينا اليوم
تنوعًا أقل وتنوعًا أقل شمولًا ،
فكيف يمكننا تجنب هذا المصير وبدلاً من ذلك
نهدف إلى عالم أفضل
أعتقد أنه عليك أن تبدأ من قبل أماه؟  ملك
خطة لما تريد أن تبدو عليه مدينتك
في عام 2040
2050. هذا هو رقم واحد وبعد ذلك
عليك أن تنظر إلى تلك الخطة
وتعديلها ، كارلو على دراية جيدة
بكيفية تغيير النقل
لقد كنت في مجال السيارات لمدة
37 عامًا  سنوات
ولم نشهد أبدًا أي خلل
كما نراه اليوم هي الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركة
carr غير الربحية التي لا يمكن أن يكون لها اختصار أكثر
ملاءمة
والذي يدرس مدى تأثير السيارات بشكل أساسي
على عالمنا الذي أحب أن أسميه
كمركز أبحاث  التي تدعم
استدامة صناعة السيارات والتنقل ،
ستغير وسائل النقل المستقبلية لدينا
تقريبًا كل جانب من جوانب الحياة ،
يمكنك قضاء أيام في القراءة عنها
جميعًا ، ولكن نظرًا لأننا اقتربنا من
خط النهاية ونفدنا من النكات المبتذلة ،
فلننتقل إلى  أبرز الأحداث التي
تبدأ بالسلامة
اليوم تحصد حوادث المرور ما يقرب من
1.3 مليون شخص سنويًا في جميع أنحاء العالم
وتجرح ما بين 20 و 50 مليون
شخص سنويًا
في مرحلة
ما ، مما لا شك فيه أن مركباتنا الأكثر ذكاءً ستقلل من هذه الأرقام تقريبًا
غالبًا ما تحدثنا عن نعم ، أريد
سيارة ذاتية القيادة
لأنك تعلم أنها ستجعل حياتي أبسط
يمكنني القيام بعمل يمكنني القيام بمهام متعددة
وهذا ليس السبب على الإطلاق الذي
تعرفه السبب هو
أنه سيحدث تأثيرًا كبيرًا في
تحسين السلامة
قد يكون الوصول إلى هذا المستقبل أكثر سهولة أيضًا ، حيث يمكن
للمجموعات التي غالبًا ما يتم تجاهلها الآن
أن يكون لديها المزيد من الخيارات إذا لم
تعد المركبات تعتمد على موقعنا.
وفي تلك السنوات العشر ، أنا متأكد من أنهم
ما زالوا يرغبون في القيام بالأشياء
التي كانوا يفعلونها من قبل
، وبالنسبة للأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة الذين
تم استبعادهم دائمًا ، فإن
هذا يفتح طريقة لتحسين حياتهم مرة أخرى ،
يمكن أن يؤدي هذا المستقبل الجديد أيضًا إلى مستوى
يعد مجال اللعب الاقتصادي
في الولايات المتحدة ، ملكية السيارات أحد
أكبر العوامل المحركة لفرص العمل
للأسر ذات الدخل المنخفض ،
ولكن إذا كانت خدمات التنقل المشتركة تخفض
تكاليف
النقل إلى  عندما لا نحتاج إلى سياراتنا الخاصة ،
قد يتم إزالة هذا الحاجز ،
ستتمكن من فتح الأبواب
التي لم تفتح اليوم ،
لذا في المستقبل يجب أن تصبح المدينة
أكثر مساواة
كما كنا نستكشف  كلما كان
المستقبل الذي يمكن الوصول إليه أكثر أمانًا ،
سمعنا الكلمات يجب ويمكن
أن تعطينا بعض الشيء إذا وضعنا تقنية جديدة ،
سنواجه نفس
المشكلات في شكل تكنولوجي مختلف
وأقوم دائمًا بإحضار الطائرات النفاثة على
سبيل المثال
نعم  إنهم يسافرون إلى منازلهم الفضائية ،
لكنهم يعانون من اختناقات مرورية لا يزال لديك
غضب على الطريق
، ولا يزال هناك سائقون سيئون لا تعرف
شيئًا ذكيًا في طرق الالتفاف
حول
الصبي ، حيث تزداد حركة المرور سوءًا
كل ليلة
لذلك لم نغير أي شيء.  وضع
تكنولوجيا جديدة لذلك علينا أن نكون
حذرين حقًا وفي
كل مرة نفكر فيها في نشر
شيء ما ، نفكر حقًا في هذا المستقبل
ثم نسخر قوة القطاعين
العام والخاص معًا
لتحقيق تلك الرحلة